j'espère que vous allez bien et que vous
passez un bon été je sais pas vous mais
moi ces dernières semaines là je revis
quoi je re goûter à la vie d'avant entre
les restaurants les cinémas c'est un
plaisir quoi c'est un plaisir mais pour
combien de temps c'est ça la question
aujourd'hui je vous parlais du vaccin et
du pass sanitaire c'est un sujet qui est
très complexe parce qu'on est tenté de
mettre les gens dans des cases
alors que c'est impossible quoi et des
gens ils sont anti vaccins et des gens
qui sont pour le vaccin mais contre le
pass annie terre il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas de problème avec le vaccin en
soi mais en fait ils n'aiment pas qu'on
leur dise quoi faire
il ya vraiment de tout il ya tellement
de raisons différentes que c'est très
difficile d'avoir un discours cohérent
et de discuter de ces choses là parce
qu'on est vite tenté de faire des prix
supposé sur les gens et ça c'est pas bon
donc c'est quelque chose que je vais
essayer d'éviter de faire dans cette
vidéo
néanmoins si vous êtes pour ou contre le
vaccin et où le pass annie terre il est
possible qu'il ya un moment dans la
vidéo où vous sentiez pas trop concerné
rester parce que c'est sûrement juste
momentanée en plus de ça dans les
réseaux sociaux comme twitter instagram
et c'est ça on nous pousse à être rapide
donc concis et à simplifier donc souvent
être dans l'erreur
là dans cette vidéo moi j'ai envie de
prendre le temps parce que j'ai le luxe
de pouvoir le faire
je vais prendre trop de temps non plus
ce que je pensais de prendre du temps
pour rien ce que je veux faire dans
cette vidéo c'est de faire comme si je
jouais à simcity c'est à dire faire
comme si j'étais le seul décisionnaire
en france face à la crise du coc vide
déjà il faut partir de la maladie et
notamment une phrase on entend souvent
qui est le co vide on le sait ça touche
surtout les vieux et c'est faux c'est
faux et ce pour 3
d'abord il n'ya pas que les formes
graves dans les formes graves on s'est
focalisé dessus parce que c'est elle qui
remplissent les hôpitaux et donc c'est
elles qui font que notre système de
santé tombe à genoux et donc c'est ce
qu'on veut éviter à tout prix mais il ya
deux formes par exemple kobe de long
vous en avez peut-être un autour de vous
voilà c'est évident comme son nom
l'indiqué qui est sur la durée ça peut
être trois mois six mois dix mois ça
peut être ça peut être long voilà ça
peut être très long avec différents
symptômes
c'est une maladie qu'on connaît encore
très mal on a du mal à évaluer les
séquelles sur le long terme
bref ses romans deuxièmement chose très
importante et souvent sous-estimé c'est
que plus le virus circule et plus il
mute et plus il mute plus on a de chance
de se retrouver avec un virus encore
plus violent les variants genre indiens
brésiliens anglais etc
ils sont arrivés à des moments où ces
pays là était vraiment sur infectées
dont qui avait aidé un moment de cas et
c'est un gros terrain de jeu pour le
virus pour qu'il puisse se multiplier et
donc muté et donc dans toutes ces
mutations et bars y en a une de temps en
temps qui écrase les autres qui est plus
forte que les autres qui est plus
violente que les autres et c'est donc
quand les jeunes qui se contaminent
entre eux certes ya pas de forme grave
mais par contre le virus peut muter à
fond et donc on peut se retrouver avec
une forme plus violente ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on veut éviter
troisièmement et pour moi c'est
peut-être le plus important on parle
souvent d'un point de vue sanitaire
basique genre les cas graves les morts
coville long ce genre de choses et le co
vide c'est pas que ça
la santé mentale l'économie enfin tout
ce qu'on vit en fait depuis plus d'un an
la enfin tout ça pour le coup ça touche
vraiment tout le monde et c'est
insupportable
et ça touche même presque plus les
jeunes que les vieux parce que c'est
peut-être une paire de la vie où on sort
plus on a plus d'interactions etc j'ai
parlé à entrer dans le cliché mais quand
j'entends legault vide ça concerne
surtout les vieux non c'est faux
quelqu'un qui me dit moi le cofide s'il
ya peu de chances que cinq buts oui
c'est vrai mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi penser au delà de la barre le
confinement le couvre-feu qui s'étend à
tous à tapas où l'expérience est quand
même bien roman j'avoue j'ai peut-être
un peu apprécié le premier confinement
et le petit côté nouveautés et ou machin
mais c'est tout vraiment tout le reste
c'est airolo voilà ça c'était un petit
topo sur qui tous locaux vides la
réponse tout art de bulletins on a quand
même pensé à quelques manières de lutter
contre cette maladie parce que ça fait
plus d'un an qu'on se la coltiner
il ya grosso modo avec les avancer la
médecine deux solutions
les traitements donc c'est en gros une
fois qu'on est infecté par la maladie
on va se guérir avec les traitement et
la prévention les vaccins qui en gros le
but c'est de prévenir le fait d'être
malade pour ne pas tomber malade donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun traitement
qui a prouvé son efficacité contre
locaux vides
il ya quelques jours ou quelques
semaines ya l'ivermectine qui a fait un
peu de bruit et c'est parce qu'ils ont
eu de bons résultats avec des hamsters
voilà où on en est dans les traitements
contre le co lead donc vincent est rien
il reste donc la vaccination alors ça ça
tombe bien on en a développé plusieurs
plus ou moins efficace avec différentes
technologies les plus répandus en france
ont d'ailleurs une efficacité assez
dingue
avec plus de 95% de protection contre
les formes graves
c'est normal de doute et notamment
douter du vaccin
c'est sain de doute et de manière
générale ce qui l'est moins par contre
c'est de rester dans ce doute et de pas
faire l'effort d'aller chercher
l'information qui pourtant est
accessible je pas donner tous les
arguments rassurants par rapport au
vaccin
tout simplement parce que j'ai fait une
vidéo sur le sujet il ya quelques mois
maintenant qui est toujours d'actualité
je vous mets un lien dans la description
il ya un autre argument par contre dont
j ai pas parlé dans ma vidéo et qui
revient récemment qui est le fait que le
vaccin est toujours en phase de test
c'est quelque chose qui revient souvent
dans les discours des personnes qui
veulent pas se faire vacciner
et c'est vrai il est toujours en phase
de test il est en phase numéro 3 alors
avant de s'alarmer faut comprendre c'est
quoi la phase de test numéro 3 la phase
de test numéro 3 elle vise à tester
l'efficacité et la sécurité du vaccin
c'est une phase qui a commencé en
janvier dernier donc janvier 2020 et en
novembre on avait déjà des résultats
résultat dont je me suis servi pour
faire ma vidéo précédent on va pas
arrêter la phase de test dès qu'on a des
premiers résultats
ces premiers résultats ils concernaient
surtout la sécurité c'est à dire les
effets secondaires puis comme je voulais
dit les effets secondaires d'un vaccin
il arrive tout de suite ils vont pas
arriver dans des années donc pourquoi on
continue cette phase de test eh ben pour
mesurer l'efficacité c'est à dire pour
mesurer combien de temps le vaccin est
efficace
combien de temps il nous protège
au bout de combien de temps faut faire
un potentiel rappelle aujourd'hui dans
le monde
à l'heure où je fais cette vidéo il y à
un milliard de personnes qui sont
totalement matinée et deux milliards en
tout qu'ils le sont partiellement
c'est énorme autre chose importante le
vaccin limite la propagation du virus
au début on savait pas on n'avait pas
les données qu'il fallait ils ont manqué
d'études là dessus maintenant on les a
on sait que ça limite drastiquement la
propagation du virus notamment pour les
armes automatiques
donc c'est ce qui est très important
parce que les à saint-thomas tic en fait
vu qu'ils n'ont pas de symptômes
ils se rendent pas compte qu'ils
transmettent le virus mais voilà quand
ils sont vaccinés
même s'ils n'ont pas de symptômes ils
transmettent beaucoup beaucoup moins là
je mets un tableau vous voyez à chaque
fois selon les études le taux de
réduction de transmission donc voilà et
à chaque fois vous avez l'étude
correspondante ça aussi entre 70% et 90%
enfin voila c'est ces deux très gros
chiffre donc j'ai une maladie qui nique
notre vie depuis plus d'un an déjà un
vaccin qui est safe hockey quand je dis
les safe je parle des vaccins arn
il ya aussi astrazeneca où il ya eu
quelques cas de thrombose en france qui
ont conduit à 12 décès et ses douze
décès sur 4,8 millions de personnes qui
ont reçu une dose ses douze décès
évidemment dommageable mais en vrai ça
ne remet pas en cause le ratio bénéfice
coût du vaccin mais ne rentre même pas
dans cette polémique là on a la chance
inouïe d'être dans un pays où on a le
choix
donc restons sur sur les vaccins arn
puisque il ya aucun cas documentés de
17h précise d'ailleurs que évidemment
quand on vaccine un milliard de
personnes
il est possible que quelqu'un se fasse
vacciner et crève le lendemain pour x ou
y raison on pourrait croire que sa cause
du vaccin mais non en fait c'est faut
vraiment séparer les corrélations et les
conséquences encore une fois sur un
milliard
ou deux milliards de personnes qui
reçoivent des doses forcément voilà dans
la vie de tous les jours il ya des gens
il ya des gens qui font des crises
cardiaques
il ya des gens qui sont je sais pas moi
qui font un avc ce genre de choses voilà
c'est des choses qui sont terribles qui
arrive vraiment tout le temps tout ça
que parfois je les anti pacs qui me dit
sur twitter
ouais je connais quelqu'un qui était
vacciné le lendemain il est décédé et
c'est sur le nombre de personnes qui
sont vaccinées
ces choses qui arrivent mais c'est pas à
cause du vaccin donc voilà je résume on
a maladie relou plus arme efficace et
c'est là en tant que décisionnaires et
gérant mode sim city je pourrais me dire
ok si je mets cette arme à disposition
les gens vont l'utiliser naturellement
mais non en fait parce que il y a les
argumentations scientifique il ya aussi
les valeurs et c'est là que ça devient
compliqué c'est de là que vient le vrai
problème de la vaccination et du passé
ni terre il faut distinguer plusieurs
choses déjà on est dans une société
capitaliste et libérale hockey depuis
des décennies et ça a changé énormément
de choses à plein de niveaux l'un d'eux
c'est l'émancipation des individus
l'essor du développement personnel dont
j'ai déjà parlé sur sa chaîne youtube ça
en fait partie c'est qu'à un moment on a
décidé de prioriser sa liberté ses
envies ses besoins à soi c'est pour ça
que éveil loose donc sociologue vraiment
très forte a écrit un bouquin et qui
s'appelle la fin de l'amour est dedans
et parle de la difficulté en fait pour
un couple aujourd'hui d'exister parce
qu'un couple c'est des compromis et on
est plus habitué à faire des compromis
je pense que j'en reparlerai ce bouquin
ce que j'avais prévu nous en parler
juste peut-être une vidéo dédiée à sa ce
que je trouve ça vraiment très
intéressant mais là ça rentre
tellement dans le sujet que je voulais
en parler maintenant le couple ils
demandent souvent à ce que sa volonté
la volonté du couple passe au dessus la
nôtre souvent on s'en rend pas compte
parce que c'est la même volonté mais
parfois parfois c'est compliqué même nos
modèles familiaux ils sont impactés si
vous allez dans d'autres pays du monde
vous allez vous rendre compte que il ya
un lien qui est vraiment différent entre
les différentes générations d'une
famille les familles sont là
vivent plus ensemble elles sont beaucoup
plus soudé et c'est chez nous c'est
moins ça c'est quand même moins ça ait
l'idée qu'on se fait de la démocratie
elle accentue ça on se dit le pouvoir au
peuple et donc à moi alors je dis pas
qu'on met des gros égoïste on reste des
humains sociaux on aide nos parents
quand on peut on fait des compromis pour
le couple quand on a envie quand on peut
et cetera pour son conjoint sa conjointe
et c'est évidemment tout ça on le fait
mais il ya cette tendance quand même qui
fait qu'on n'est pas trop habitué à
faire des choses pour des gens qu'on ne
connaît pas notamment pour le collectif
aujourd'hui le moment on ag le plus pour
notre société
c'est sûrement le moment où en fait on
paye nos impôts et c'est tellement
invisible genre à la source et cetera on
se rend à peine compte les gens qui
refusent qu'on leur dise quoi faire je
les comprends la plupart des maladies on
s'en fout les gens font ce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent fumer un paquet par
jour ok ok on va juste monter le prix de
la clope et on va utiliser cet argent
pour l'assurance maladie parce que ça
nous coûte cher les cancers du poumon
les gens veulent pas faire attention sur
toi ok on va pas leur interdire de
manger trop manger mal on va juste faire
des campagnes genre manger cinq fruits
et légumes etc
voilà on va essayer de faire ce qu'on
peut mais on va pas leur interdire de
manger ce qu'ils veulent mais là le coc
vide c'est différent parce qu'un mot clé
qui est hyper important c'est contagion
c'est une maladie qu'on attrape par les
autres et qu'on refile aux autres dans
des proportions énormes
et ça ça fait qu'en fait on est tous
dans le même bateau et on doit
solutionner ce problème ensemble
le vrai problème du vaccin c'est pascal
dedans ça on l'a vu ces safe son vrai
problème c'est que ce injecter un vaccin
dont on n'a pas forcément besoin à celle
individuelle
ça va chercher une partie en nous qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de solliciter c'est
la corde du collectif est au contraire
ça fait face à une partie qu'on
sollicite très souvent c'est notre envie
propre notre désir propre
quand je dis très souvent ce même tous
les jours n'est en fait le choix du
vaccin c'est un choix de société
qu'on soit d'accord ou non pour éviter
les formes graves les morts l'écho vie
de long et les mutations
il ya plein de choix de sociétés avec
lesquelles les gens sont pas forcément
d'accord quand on a aboli la peine de
mort les gens étaient pour la garder
genre si on avait fait un référendum
la peine de mort est resté quand on a
fait passer
la loi du mariage pour tous elle est
constamment des manifs la manif pour
tous constamment s'étaient toutes les
semaines je crois et ça ne s'arrêtait
pas et pourtant on a quand même fait
passer cette loi parce que c'est un
choix de société
la vaccination c'est pareil en fait le
passé ni terre c'est pareil c'est un
choix de société et on est obligé de
passer par là pour se sortir de cette
merde qu'on vit depuis un an voire plus
le truc c'est qu'il ya une vraie
défiance aux vaccins en général dans
notre pays
c'est pour ça qu'on en a rendu
obligatoire plusieurs en 2018 à la 11
qui sont obligatoires en tout et nos
pays voisins
eh ben ils ont moins de vaccins
obligatoires que nous parce qu'en fait
ils se vaccine de même mais le terrain
anti vax a pris beaucoup de place en
france
si bien que par exemple en 2016 et une
baisse de la couverture vaccinale de 5%
ce qui est énorme
on a même vu ressurgir des maladies et
pire en a même failli la merde
dans d'autres pays je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de cette famille française
qui avait un enfant non vaccinés contre
la rougeole et qui est partie au costa
rica et qui a réimporté la rougeole au
costa rica alors que ça faisait cinq ans
qui s'était débarrassée de la rougeole
alors comment la gérer cette défiance et
ben en vrai pareil si on reprend cette
casquette un peu de deux gestionnaires
simcity quoi décisionnaires pas ça tout
ça faudrait dialoguer on a dialogué
faudrait des bunkers les arguments voilà
prendre le temps vraiment de
déconstruire ce discours là parce que
c'est de la pédagogie c'est du dialogue
etc
mais c'est très difficile parce que à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux ça circule à
une vitesse folle sans anti discours
c'est très difficile à contrer moi j'ai
des gens dans ma famille qui parfois
m'envoient des messages qu'ils reçoivent
et donc j'ai encore la chance qu'ils me
les envoie comme ça je peux réagir avec
eux et donc des bunkers certaines choses
mais vraiment et parfois y est c'est des
mensonges noir sur blanc quoi et
généralement ça se débloque en une
recherche google
mais le truc c'est que ce travail de
dialogue etc et de déconstruire les
faits que nous sans faille de long terme
qui prend du temps or là on est dans une
situation d'urgence qui implique de
faire vacciner le plus de monde le plus
vite possible quand on prend tout ça en
compte comprend l'urgence de la
situation en compte
on prend le fait que notre pays il a
cette défiance là que d'autres voisins
n'ont pas forcément etc
quand on prend en compte que le vaccin
on sait qu'il est safe que c'est notre
meilleure arme pour sortir de ce merdier
qu'on vit depuis autant de temps c'est
pas déconnant que notre société ait
fasse ce choix là ce choix là il est
raisonnée il est logique il fait sans ça
le passé à lithaire ça ressemble
fortement à une obligation on va pas se
mentir on pas joué la carte de nan mais
on n'est pas obligé on n'oblige personne
jette a besoin d'aller au resto tu as
besoin d'aller au ciné ou n'importe quoi
magenta besoin du passé ni terre c'est
une option forme d'obligation mais en
fait ce qu'ils disent eux pas sanitaire
c'est assez simple il dit si vous voulez
faire partie de la société et bénéficier
de ce que la société à offrir genre les
restaurants les signer ce genre de
choses c'est un choix de société
vous pouvez ne pas vous vacciner mais
dans ce cas là vous vous excluez de la
société c'est ça qui dit le pass anita
alors est ce que ces nouveaux qu'on nous
force à nous injecter un peu de corps
non la dire il ya onze vaccins qui sont
obligatoires ce vaccin là il est aussi
safe que les onze dont on a parlé et
puis même si par exemple vous voulez
voyager au congo vous devez avoir un
certificat de vaccination par rapport à
la fièvre jaune
sinon je n'ai pas la télé les vaccins et
leurs obligations font déjà partie de
notre quotidien et ça semble raisonnable
quand elle est safe et que c'est entre
meilleure arme de l'utiliser
collectivement je dis beaucoup de voir
le mot safe c'est à dire sur je le dis
je me suis pris pour un bilingue là ou
quoi
la zt allsafe semaine c'est pourquoi je
dis safe non je dis puisque parfois dans
les commentaires il ya des gens qui sont
vraiment des amoureux des défenseurs de
la langue française que j'embrasse
évidemment disent ouais les anglicismes
on n'est pas obligé you right with you
have to
ce qui est intéressant c'est que le fait
que soit l'autorité qui nous pousse à
nous vacciner ça ouvre la porte à tous
les fantasmes
michel foucault par les mêmes du bio
pouvoir et la gouvernementalité décor ça
fait quoi une autre valeur importante
qu'ont certaines personnes qui veulent
pas se faire vacciner qui est la
sacralisation
de la nature et du corps notre corps est
sacrée et donc on n'a pas nous dire ce
qu'il faut mettre dedans même certains
qui vont plus loin et qui disent qu'ils
vu que les sacrés il peut se défendre
tout seul
d'une certaine manière ça généralement
c'est les gens qui utilisent très peu de
médicaments qui les ai vite et c'est
tout ça c'est sans jugement de valeur
moi même je sais pas pourquoi genre
j'aime pas trop pendue doliprane quoi
genre quand j'ai juste mal à la tête je
suis là georges je vis mon mal de tête
fut l'agent non non j'ai mal à mon corps
va supporter d'armes à la tête des gens
comme si le fait de vivre la douleur ça
me rendait plus fort alors que je pense
que je prendrai un doliprane j'aurai moi
ma tête je suis plus heureux on parle
des ventes valeur il ya la logique et
les raisons scientifiques ya les valeurs
et ça c'est plus compliqué mais pour
revenir sur le côté genre sacralisation
du corps on n'a pas à me dire ce que
jamais dedans c'est faux c'est faux on
le fait déjà en fait la société nous
impose mettre des choses dans notre
corps comme la société nous sauve notre
corps quand il en a besoin
grâce à notre système de santé vous
n'êtes pas né ni grandi seul sans l'aide
de personne
la société elle vous a fait naître nous
a instruits à vous accompagner
c'est un non-sens de penser qu'on est
totalement libre dans cette société on
ne l'est pas évidemment qu'on ne l'est
pas il ya un tas de règles qu'on suit et
qui sont tellement imprégnés en nous
qu'on fait même plus attention voulait
quitter la société est allé jouer les
ermites barinque pour vous nourrir et
survivent à votre environnement
faire une telle galère vous allez être
encore plus esclave que maintenant en
fait on a beaucoup soutenu que le passé
intêrét est liberticide
les gens adorent ce mot tejari fait un
peu intelligent et tout voilà c'est pas
vrai pour revenir à ce que ça veut dire
en fait la liberté elle n'a pas de sens
si on peut pas en jouir
si on veut pas l'exprimer dans un monde
qui est confiné avec des couvre-feux etc
ou en fait rien qu'en parlant avec
quelqu'un d'autre je peux
potentiellement lui nuire
elle est où la liberté quelle liberté à
rien d'avoir une liberté dans ce monde
là en fait on va pousser l'exemple plus
loin mais dans un monde sans cadre
anarchie totale sans règles et que
l'état peut même protégées quelle
liberté je peux exprimer
le pass annie terre il nous enlève pas
notre liberté il nous la donne en fait
il nous permet de la garder il nous
permet de pouvoir exprimer notre liberté
tous sauf liberticide c'est l'exact
opposé le fait que les gens se révoltent
c'est prévisible et j'ai presque envie
de dire normal on a eu les premiers
vaccins au 19e siècle
on avait ce genre de tableaux ou
vraiment genre les effets secondaires du
vaccin son hardcore fayez karam en dd
des monstres qui sortent des bras quoi
on avait aussi des révoltes genre
certaine à rio en 1904 même fait des
morts il y avait aussi des arguments
religieux qui s'ajoutaient aux arguments
qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc c'était une galère et pourtant on a
quand même rendu des vaccins
obligatoires en france en 1902 il ya eu
la variole en 1938 celui contre la
diphtérie en 1940 celui contre le
tétanos est en 64 celui contre la
poliomyélite voilà des maladies qu'on
connaît vaguement de non justement grâce
à ces décisions
maintenant faut réussir à dépasser cette
première réaction de peur au changement
je pense que mon but avec cette vidéo
c'est pas d'inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner puisque la plupart d'entre eux
vont le faire
quoi qu'il arrive mais le but et vous
allez prendre un petit peu pour un saint
mais le but ce qu'ils y est avec le
smile quoi parce que ce vaccin c'est une
chance incroyable et le prendre tous ces
sortir de cette merde ensemble et
l'autre but c'est aussi de m'adresser à
ceux qui sont pour le vaccin qui se
vaccinent etc mais qui sont contre ce
pas sanitaires par contre je parlerai
pas des comparaison odieuse qui peut y
avoir entre le passé ni terre et le
nazisme et la shoah
je parlerai pas non plus du fait qu'il y
ait certains dans des vaccins qui
viennent attaquer des centres de
vaccination empêcher les gens de se
faire vacciner alors qu'en plus il ya
plein de partie dans le monde qui n'ont
pas encore les vaccins en tout cas qui
qui aimeraient avoir autant de doses que
ça qu'on a
voilà je parlerai pas tout ça parce que
parce que j'ai parlé de prendre le temps
pour ça la vidéo avait déjà assez longue
en tout cas j'espère que cette vidéo va
permettre à certaines personnes de
reconsidérer peut-être leur position et
j'espère qu'elle va permettre à d'autres
de donner des arguments en fait des
arguments qu'il faut pour dans les
conversations quoi pour si vous voulez
comme je le dis un peu plus tôt dans la
vidéo faire ce travail de détricotage de
déblocage et c'est par rapport aux faits
qui nous voilà j'espère que ça peut vous
aider sachant qu'il manque beaucoup de
choses et c'est difficile de tout
énumérer
on aurait pu parler genre il ya un
exemple qui revient souvent contre
exemple qui est israël qui pourtant a
vacciné de ouf on est en fait israël n'a
pas vaccinés tant que ça si on regarde
le pourcentage de la population vaccinée
à l'heure où je fais cette vidéo il doit
être de l'it et de 60% à peu près entre
57 et 63 suivant si c'est une ou deux
doses je crois de mémoire
bref voilà il manque beaucoup de choses
je peux pas tout faire dans tous les cas
prenez soin de vous passer un bon été
qui fait au maximum avant qu'on sera
confiné pour une quatrième vague parce
qu'on n'aura pas atteint les mythes et
collective le pis ciao